$4,500 that's what the Alienware area 51
with Triathlon i nee TS we have in the
office costs and the 4k monitor we have
is another $684 it runs games pretty
well at 4k and gaming at 2160p is sick
but I'm guessing that's too rich for
your blood
it sure is for me our story doesn't end
here it's just begun to get 60 frames
per second in 4k with three 90s you're
not gonna be running Ultra settings on
every game especially not which are
three for example but 4k is super
impressive even at 30 to 40 frames per
second I've been testing out all the
games have been playing lately so I have
a good frame of reference for how things
should look and feel games like
Wolfenstein the old blood in GTA 5 to
rally project cars Far Cry 4 and
deletion 3 unsurprisingly they all look
super nice at 2160p how to describe it
it did it doesn't add to the realism but
it makes everything look crisp focus it
makes the game's assets and props look
like you've ripped them out of the game
and you're looking at them in the actual
world that's not even getting to like
grass and trees until it's really hot so
let's go
I was actually surprised to even see
that how good it looked like sitting
close to that monitor playing it on a PC
it was so beautiful I'm like shocked
it's amazing what kirat looks like in 4k
when you're in the Himalayas you can see
the draw distance is unbelievable the
mountains the detail in the clouds you
really feel like you're in this
beautiful serene in
something like GTA 5 when it's at 4k it
looks pretty remarkable and it's just
little things like the detail and the
tires and when you're doing burnouts and
the rim spinning that kind of stuff when
you're traveling on dirt you know you
just you see more detail you see more
sharpness yeah I mean I I tried GTA 2
and wasn't really into it but with
something like The Witcher where you're
outside all the time you have the trees
in the distance you have all the plants
and everything around like I think 4k
really shines in that environment
people's faces look so surreal like as
far as like wrinkles and someone's eyes
squinting and just forming for
expressions is I don't think I've ever
seen it before it does smell of lilac
and gooseberries we also tested a Titan
X on a core i7 4930 K and got playable
results across all the affirmation games
even The Witcher 3 was running at 35 to
40 frames per second at 4k on high
settings we don't have one in the office
but what about an R 9 295x2 from AMD
those cards performs so well at 4k and
the only cost six hundred and nineteen
dollars now then you also need a monitor
and you can get the non g-sync 28 inch
60 Hertz Acer beauty for about 450 but
you know what's better than 2160p 60
1440p 144 maybe even 1080p 144 playing
all those games I mentioned before at
1080p 144 was an even more eye-opening
experience for me than 4k I couldn't
believe how amazing far cry 4 felt at
over 100 frames per second and the car
games were just so fluid at that speed
too I swear I was playing better it's
impossible to go back
we've been using a $330 LG g m7 t 7 144
hertz 1080p display at 24 inches to test
out some of this over a hundred FPS
gaming I really felt like it does give
you this great feeling of dexterity feel
like you've way more control even when I
turn 360 I just saw everything and I
prefer that so much I like especially
when it's heavy action oriented that you
get the higher frame rate me that's just
like that
yeah Far Cry looked outstanding high
frame rate it's one of those things
where like once you've played it you
don't want to go back like and I want
the PC rig to handle that when I played
The Witcher like a really high frame
rate at 1080 but I think it was cool but
personally I'd prefer something at 4k
and get that experience running at least
at 30 frames per second but I mean maybe
an FPS or something the frame rate
matters but for a game like this where I
really want to be immersed in the beauty
of it I'd go for the quality of 4k I
know it's hard to form an opinion
without seeing this stuff but for me I'm
not gonna chase 4k I don't think I think
the 2k 144 gaming is where it's at
that's where I want my money to go heck
even 1080p 144 is good enough for me to
chase I'm ready to drop $1,000 worth of
upgrades and I can see it get it - so
only you can answer if it's worth it for
you help each other out by sharing your
experience with 4k or high frame rate
stuff in the comments below we sure
appreciate it thanks for watching thank
you
you